[Musique]
en 74 un candidat fait sensation avec un
simple verre d'eau
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qui va se passer
bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes animaux
bon je m'en souviens pas à jeter un peu
petit accord
c'était dans les spots de la campagne
officielle rené dumont le premier
candidat écolo qui prêchait assez
largement dans le désert les communistes
ont mis longtemps à se réveiller sur la
question de l'écologie n'ont pas écouté
vous savez pour préparer cette élection
présidentielle j'ai ressorti des
archives des précédentes élections
présidentielles où nous avions présenté
des candidats et j'ai ressorti un quatre
pages qui avait publié robert hue dans
la campagne de 95
sur l'enjeu environnemental et
écologique et le besoin de sortir d'un
système économique qui
épuise autant les hommes que la planète
et nos ressources naturelles nous avions
à l'époque mis l'accent sur le besoin de
développer les réseaux ferrés le
transport des marchandises de lutter
contre la pollution de l'air le
réchauffement climatique c'était écrit
noir sur blanc et donc
c'était il ya plus de 20 ans et donc
nous portions déjà l'exigence de changer
de système économique et des logiques de
profit qui épuise la planète et les
hommes parce que vous savez le
capitalisme vert que défend certains
écologistes ça ne marche pas le problème
c'est pas la couleur c'est le
capitalisme et nous c'est à ça qu'on
s'attaque
[Musique]